un château des rivières qui rappelle le
centre val de loire
voici à quoi ressemble le nouveau logo
des produits issus de la région et pour
l'obtenir il faut répondre à des
critères bien précis
c'est quand même très important pour
nous de de nous démarquer des filières
industrielles qui ne brasse pas du tout
de la même façon que nous qui ne brasse
pas avec les mêmes les mêmes produits ou
plutôt qu'ils utilisent des produits que
nous n'utilisons pas notamment des
additifs de synthèse dans cette épicerie
fine beaucoup de produits du terroir
comme ces lentilles du berry qui ont
aussi obtenu le logo les clients ils
sont ils sont demandeurs de produits qui
sont faits dans la région soit pour
offrir à de la famille soit pour
consommer ce sera un indicateur encore
plus plus pratique pour tout le monde
même pour nous et les consommateurs
aussi sont séduits par l'idée gens
feront tout de suite parce qu'en fait
j'ai hésité avec plusieurs miel mais
c'est vrai que si je vois que ses
proches de chez nous bien sûr j'y vais
lancé par la région la marque c'est du
centre permettra aussi de renforcer
l'attractivité du territoire
selon le président de la région quand on
fait du tourisme ont envie de voir les
beaux châteaux ont envie de voir la
loire ici en centre val de loire nos
parcs nos jardins nos parcs naturels
régionaux cathédrale on envie de tout ça
on a aussi envie de rencontrer des
agriculteurs de notre rencontre et des
artisans
on a envie du plaisir du bien manger on
a envie du plaisir de la gastronomie des
produits de qualité au total 60
entreprises ont déjà rejoint
l'initiative
objectif atteindre les 10 mille produits